Katrina: 之前跟他说我觉得不太想谈恋爱那种
Katrina: Earlier, I told him that I don't really want to date.
Nicous: 李欣达李欣达
Nicous: Li Xinda, Li Xinda
Nicous: 嗯嗯快点跟他说挖醒他哈哈哈
Nicous: Yeah, yeah, quickly tell him, wake him up, hahaha
Katrina: 我去
Katrina: Oh my god
Jack: 你们你们
Jack: You guys, you guys
Jack: 刚才情感召唤了
Jack: Just now, the emotions were summoned
Nicous: 情感上他老觉得他觉得自己会越界
Nicous: Emotionally, he always feels like he might cross the line
Nicous: 真真不是我在想情感价都到哪了
Nicous: Really, really, I'm not thinking about the emotional value
Katrina: 不是我在想
Katrina: It's not that I'm thinking
Jack: 情感召唤到哪了
Jack: Where are the emotions summoned to?
Jack: 来来来不是
Jack: Come on, come on, no
Katrina: 他喜欢我可以
Katrina: He likes me, okay
Shure的女友:stop stop
Shure's GF: Stop, stop
Katrina: 但是我怕是因为我的一些言论让他
Katrina: But I'm afraid it's because of some of my comments that made him
Nicous: 停
Nicous: Stop
Shure的女友:something i think can no sorry
Shure's GF: Something I think can no sorry
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: Exactly, exactly
Shure的女友:停止你的所有脑补
Shure's GF: Stop all your overthinking
Shure的女友:现在你其实其实他们都应该去回避一下
Shure's GF: Now, actually, they should all avoid this a bit
Jack: 我来说
Jack: Let me say
Nicous: 啊不回避啊
Nicous: Ah, no need to avoid
Shure的女友:就是你现在你的所有思想都应该是OK
Shure's GF: What I mean is, all your thoughts should be okay
Jake:啊走了走了
Jake: Ah, let's go, let's go
Jake:没关系他录着了哈哈哈
Jake: It's okay, he's recording, hahaha
Shure的女友:用用用用一句就是就是
Shure's GF: Just, just, just
Shure的女友:就是就是东北人比较比较会讲话
Shure's GF: Like, Northeastern people are more articulate
Shure的女友:就是姐就是女王
Shure's GF: Like, I'm the queen
Shure的女友:你现在就应该觉得哦OK
Shure's GF: You should feel like, oh, okay
Nicous: 什么叫东北人会讲话
Nicous: What do you mean Northeastern people are articulate?
Shure的女友:就是所有人都应该围绕着我生活
Shure's GF: Like, everyone should live around me
Shure的女友:所有事情都应该围绕着我去发展
Shure's GF: Everything should revolve around me
Shure的女友:就是你就是的top one
Shure's GF: You're the top one
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yes, yes, yes
Katrina: 这个我是就是一直的一个理念
Katrina: This has always been my philosophy
Jake:咱要回避不用回避不用回避
Jake: Should we avoid it? No need, no need to avoid
Katrina: 不会觉得
Katrina: I don't think
Katrina: 因为这个男生会影响到我的人
Katrina: Because this guy will affect me
Katrina: 我的性格啊什么什么的
Katrina: My personality or whatever
Katrina: 但是
Katrina: But
Shure的女友:OK
Shure's GF: OK
Shure的女友:if you are the Queen
Shure's GF: If you are the Queen
Katrina: 那我就
Katrina: Then I
Katrina: 那我就可以给他随便发
Katrina: Then I can just send him anything
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry
那我就可以给他随便发
Katrina: Then I can just send him anything
Shure的女友:如果你是那个女王所有人都该爱你啊
Shure's GF: If you are the Queen, everyone should love you
Shure的女友:所有人都该爱你
Shure's GF: Everyone should love you
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 就整个语言转换成英文
Shure: Just switch the whole language to English
Nicous: 我没说你说的不对啊
Nicous: I'm not saying you're wrong
Nicous: 就是他的点在于他刚刚跟我说
Nicous: It's just that his point is he just told me
Jake:OK再再喝点
Jake: OK, drink some more
Nicous: 他说他做的事情有没有约见
Nicous: He said whether what he's doing is appropriate
Jake:再再喝点
Jake: Drink some more
Katrina: 哈哈嗯我是怕我遇见导致他
Katrina: Haha, I was afraid my encounter would lead to him
Jake:哈哈会法语吗
Jake: Haha, do you speak French?
Nicous: 如果说真的有越界
Nicous: If he really crossed the line
Nicous: 那是那个男的的问题啊
Nicous: That's the guy's problem
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry
Shure: 现在是还会转换中文哦
Shure: Now it can switch back to Chinese
Shure的女友:啊sorry如果你跟所有的异性
Shure's GF: Ah sorry, if you interact with all the opposite sex like this
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 不会转换中文OK
Shure: It won't switch back to Chinese, OK
Nicous: 都是这么相处的话
Nicous: If this is how you interact with everyone
Shure: 那我每次我要跟他说中文
Shure: Then every time I have to speak to him in Chinese
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Nicous: 你不需要你担心
Nicous: You don't need to worry
Nicous: 你有没有越界
Nicous: Whether you crossed the line
Nicous: 就只是因为他对你所有的
Nicous: It's just because he's reacting to all your actions
Jake:你应该先学
Jake: You should first learn
Jake:应该是骗局
Jake: It must be a scam
Shure的女友:对你对他对你所有的动作
Shure's GF: All your actions towards him
Shure的女友:还有一些另类想象就是他的问题
Shure's GF: And some of his fantasies, that's his problem
Shure的女友:对无所谓你喜不喜欢他
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter if you like him or not
Shure的女友:但他肯定是喜欢你
Shure's GF: But he definitely likes you
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Jake:yes
Jake: Yes
Shure的女友:你不需要对这些东西进行一些内耗
Shure's GF: You don't need to waste energy on these things
Shure的女友:就是你做你自己就可以了
Shure's GF: Just be yourself
Shure的女友:你不要其实无所谓了
Shure's GF: It doesn't really matter
男嘉宾:你不要听别人的
Male Guest: Don't listen to others.
Shure的女友:你如果喜欢他OK
Shure's GFa: If you like him, it's okay.
Shure的女友:我采耳
Shure's GFa: I'll clean your ears.
Katrina: 主要是我一直不知道他喜欢我
Katrina: Mainly, I never knew he liked me.
Shure的女友:我觉得喜欢他
Shure's GFa: I think you like him.
Katrina: 我知道今天给我说的这
Katrina: I know, he told me today.
Jake:now you know
Jake: Now you know.
Nicous: 你喜欢他非常好
Nicous: If you like him, that's great.
Nicous: 你不喜欢他
Nicous: If you don't like him,
Nicous: 你开心就可以了
Nicous: As long as you're happy.
Nicous: 对啊他开不开心关你屁事
Nicous: Yeah, why should you care if he's happy?
Katrina: 哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh.
Nicous: 那我觉得
Nicous: So I think...
Katrina: 只是我现在非常震惊而已
Katrina: I'm just really shocked right now.
Shure的女友:你可以忽略他所有的话
Shure's GFa: You can ignore everything he says.
Shure的女友:但是你可以在意他一句话
Shure's GFa: But you can care about one thing he says.
Shure的女友:就是你开开心就可以了啊
Shure's GFa: Just be happy.
Katrina: 那是那是
Katrina: Yes, yes.
Katrina: 嗯但是但是我知道他喜欢我以后
Katrina: Yeah, but knowing he likes me now,
Katrina: 我知道他喜欢我以后
Katrina: Knowing he likes me now,
Katrina: 我就感觉没法用哥们了那种
Katrina: I feel like I can't just be buddies with him.
Nicous: 那是你的问题
Nicous: That's your problem.
Shure的女友:你这还是你当哥们都OK了
Shure's GFa: You can still be buddies with him, it's okay.
Katrina: 相处了
Katrina: To hang out.
Katrina: 我就不想给他发那种东西了
Katrina: I just don't want to send him those kinds of things anymore.
Jake:那就不发了
Jake: Then don't send them.
Jake:对他都邀请来了
Jake: Yeah, he invited us all.
Jake:我们有gaste就很好
Jake: As long as we have guests, it's great.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你都护体达成了是吧哈哈哈
Katrina: You got your protection, right? Hahaha.
Shure的女友:我我我我和修硕大一谈过一个月还是两个月
Shure's GFa: I, I, I, I dated Shure for a month or two in freshman year.
Nicous: 1个月一个月
Nicous: One month, one month.
Shure的女友:一个月还是两个月吧
Shure's GFa: One month or two months?
Shure的女友:你知道多久
Shure's GFa: Do you know how long?
Shure: 线上的
Shure: Online.
Shure: 差不多啊
Shure: About that, yeah.
Shure的女友:OK反正就是
Shure's GFa: Okay, anyway,
Shure的女友:反正就一两个月吧
Shure's GFa: Anyway, one or two months.
Shure的女友:然后我们两个的就是一个专业嘛
Shure's GFa: And we were in the same major.
Shure的女友:我们两个辅导员
Shure's GFa: Our counselor...
Shure的女友:然后一直以为我们就是那种怂类群
Shure: And then I always thought we were just that kind of timid group.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure的女友:灵魂伴侣
Shure: Soulmates.
Katrina: 我也觉得你俩是灵魂伴侣
Katrina: I also think you two are soulmates.
Katrina: 他当时跟我讲了以后
Katrina: When he told me back then,
Katrina: 我就觉得你俩是灵魂伴侣
Katrina: I thought you two were soulmates.
Shure的女友:对然后中间就是从从大一分手之后
Shure: Yeah, and then after we broke up in our first year,
Shure的女友:他也谈过
Shure: He dated others.
Shure的女友:我也谈过
Shure: I dated others.
Shure的女友:然后后来发现
Shure: And then later found out,
Shure的女友:嗯OK到大四了
Shure: Hmm, okay, by our fourth year.
Shure的女友:然后哎
Shure: Then, hey,
Jack: 这个故事也很令人好奇啊
Jack: This story is really intriguing.
Jack: 怎么就转回来了
Jack: How did you two get back together?
Shure的女友:所以说很复杂
Shure: So, it's really complicated.
Shure的女友:哈哈那就讲很复杂
Shure: Haha, let’s just say it's very complicated.
Shure的女友:讲讲讲然后现在又在一起了
Shure: And now we're together again.
Jake:这能录对吧
Jake: Can we record this?
Jack: 这能录对吧
Jack: Can we record this?
这个能录这能录
Can we record this?
Jake:这个能录好
Jake: This can be recorded well.
Jake:好记一下
Jake: Alright, take a note.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jack: 哈哈这个不能录
Jack: Haha, this can't be recorded.
Jack: 不能录就录我
Jack: If it can't be recorded, then record me.
Shure的女友:一会你开心就好
Lucia: As long as you're happy later.
Jake:刚刚卡掉
Jake: It just got stuck.
Shure的女友:这就开始开心就好了
Lucia: Just start enjoying now.
Shure的女友:你不管他们怎么样
Lucia: Don't mind them.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mhm.
Shure的女友:就是如果他们会对这些东西
Lucia: If they care about these things...
Jake:哎呦卧槽
Jake: Oh, damn.
Shure的女友:有一些在意
Lucia: ...if they care about these things.
Shure的女友:那你就可以把他
Lucia: Then you can...
Katrina: 因为就是有种不想惹麻烦的感觉
Katrina: Because it feels like I don't want to cause trouble.
Katrina: 如果他就是喜欢我就不想跟他说话了
Katrina: If he likes me, I don't want to talk to him.
Shure的女友:你就可以把这些性归
Lucia: You can attribute this behavior...
Shure的女友:归类于他不尊重女性
Lucia: ...to him not respecting women.
Shure的女友:就哈哈开心就好
Lucia: Just laugh and be happy.
Katrina: 为啥
Katrina: Why?
Katrina: 他喜欢我就可以
Katrina: As long as he likes me, that's enough.
Jake:可以你你你想你怎么想都行
Jake: Sure, you can think whatever you like.
Jake:我们你怎么想都行
Jake: Whatever you think is fine with us.
Shure: 哈哈被夸了
Shure: Haha, got a compliment.
Katrina: 瞬间你全不是
Katrina: Suddenly, you're not all that.
Katrina: 他喜欢我可以
Katrina: He likes me, it's fine.
Katrina: 我确实应该被喜欢的
Katrina: I definitely deserve to be liked.
Shure的女友:你开心就好
Shure: As long as you're happy.
Katrina: 嗯嗯嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Jack: 还是还是抓重点
Jack: Let's still focus on the main point.
Katrina: 我只是我只是刚开始一下没接
Katrina: I was just a bit caught off guard at first.
Katrina: 因为没有只是只是
Katrina: Because it was just...
Katrina: 我那个就有点震惊而已
Katrina: I was just a bit shocked.
Katrina: 就是我觉得是好朋友
Katrina: I thought we were good friends.
Katrina: 我觉得
Katrina: I think...
Shure的女友:因为这个
Shure: Because of this...
Katrina: 我们两个分手之后
Katrina: After we broke up...
Katrina: 呃怎么讲呢他去谈了个女生
Katrina: Um, how should I put it, he started dating a girl.
Katrina: 我也去谈了个女生
Katrina: And I also started dating a girl.
Jack: 啊哈哈哈哈这个是可以录的
Jack: Hahaha, this can be recorded.
Katrina: 厉害厉害
Katrina: Impressive, impressive.
Jack: 这个这个录上了
Jack: This is recorded.
Jake:这咋这咋
Jake: How did this...
Nicous: 没事我感觉输一局稳了
Nicous: No worries, I feel like I've already lost a round.
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
老板:这个这个要到example里边
Boss: This needs to go into the example section.
Jake:谁敢B我
Jake: Who dares to B me?
Jack: 你逼随便逼
Jack: You can B as much as you want.
Jake:多多多多聊聊多聊聊
Jake: More, more, talk more.
Jack: 这个这个好好聊聊多聊聊多聊聊
Jack: Yeah, let's talk more, talk more.
Jake:多聊聊多聊聊
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Jack: 啊啊其实这个是要做聊聊吗
Jack: Ah, should we really talk more about this?
Jake:这个哈哈怎么这么聊啊
Jake: Haha, how should we even talk about this?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:怎么这么聊啊
Jake: How do we even talk about this?
Jack: double呢还是怎么地呢
Jack: Double it or what?
Jake:你怎么这么聊起来了
Jake: How did you even start talking like this?
Katrina: 我也有很多异性朋友
Katrina: I also have a lot of friends of the opposite sex.
Jack: 这个聊这个聊
Jack: Talk about this, talk about this.
Jake:这个聊法可能
Jake: The way we're talking about this is...
Jake:就给我一句话我靠
Jake: Just give me a sentence, damn.
Jake:我靠哈哈
Jake: Damn, haha.
Katrina: 那是有意思
Katrina: That's interesting.
Katrina: 以后就变得很尴尬了
Katrina: It will become awkward in the future.
Jake:就给一句
Jake: Just give me one sentence.
谢斌竹:每个人想法不一样 所以这都无所谓啊
谢斌竹:你有什么可
Nicous: 对啊他的想法是他的
Nicous: Yeah, his thoughts are his thoughts.
Nicous: 你的想法是你
Nicous: Your thoughts are yours.
Katrina: 不是今天我我只是震惊一下而已
Katrina: No, today I was just shocked.
Jack: 我知道你的状态
Jack: I know your state.
Jack: 就是你特别你好
Jack: You're just really, you're good.
Jake:你好
Jake: You're good.
Tasha:我GDP崩了
Tasha: My GDP crashed.
Katrina: 啊啊啊
Katrina: Ah, ah, ah.
为什么Tasha:
Why Tasha:
Katrina: 因为我当时一直以为
Katrina: Because I always thought...
Jake:你GDP崩了
Jake: Your GDP crashed?
Katrina: 就是每个人的相处方式不一样
Katrina: Everyone's way of getting along is different.
Tasha:就是回答不了我的问题了
Tasha: I can't answer my own question anymore.
Katrina: 可能就是我告诉你不要自作多情
Katrina: Maybe I told you not to be too sentimental.
Jake:来 来给你搞
Jake: Come on, I'll get it for you.
给你给你花钱
I'll spend money on you.
Jake:给你花钱
Jake: I'll spend money on you.
Katrina: 我一直觉得这样子
Katrina: I always thought like this.
Jack: 国内就是
Jack: In the country...
谢斌竹:我个人觉得   觉得   就是  很难自作多情
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Katrina: 就是当时被北邮男搞了一下
Katrina: I was tricked by a guy from Beiyou.
Katrina: 以后我觉得
Katrina: After that, I felt...
Jake:别冻着啊
Jake: Don't catch a cold.
Nicous: 或者说他就是喜欢暧昧
Nicous: 就是作为被喜欢的那一方是哎呦我靠
Nicous: As the person being liked, it's like "oh damn."
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh damn.
Jake:这你妈
Jake: This is...
Nicous: 作为被喜欢的那一方其实是哎
Nicous: As the person being liked, actually it's like "hey."
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 我会感觉到有点奇怪
Katrina: I would feel a bit strange.
Katrina: 但是我总觉得是
Katrina: But I always think...
Katrina: 每个人相处方式不一样哎
Katrina: Everyone's way of getting along is different.
Nicous: 你觉得他喜欢你
Nicous: You think he likes you.
Nicous: 他肯定也是喜欢你
Nicous: He definitely likes you too.
Jake:我靠你怎么感觉出来了
Jake: Damn, how did you figure that out?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Jake:这这
Jake: This this
Katrina: 你说北邮的还是今天这个
Katrina: Are you talking about Beiyou or today?
Jake:北邮的 你这个不是没感觉出来
Jake: Beiyou. Didn't you feel that one?
Tasha:北邮的是哪个
Tasha: Which one from Beiyou?
Jake:你这个不是没感觉出来吗
Jake: Didn't you feel anything from this one?
Katrina: 北邮这个
Katrina: The Beiyou one.
Katrina: 当时10月份对我爆好你知道吗
Katrina: Back in October, he was super nice to me, you know?
Katrina: 每一句就是他做的
Katrina: Every single thing he did was great.
Katrina: 比我前男友谈五年都做得好
Katrina: Better than my ex of five years.
Katrina: 就我俩只出去玩过两次
Katrina: We only went out twice.
Katrina: 就是那种贴心程度包括情绪价值给的
Katrina: But he was so considerate and gave me so much emotional value.
Katrina: 然后后来12月的时候
Katrina: Then later in December,
Katrina: 他就突然就是感觉干嘛来着
Katrina: He suddenly seemed different.
Katrina: 不知道他说他忙工作去了你知道吗
Katrina: He said he was busy with work, you know?
Katrina: 就感觉有落差感
Katrina: I felt a sense of disparity.
Nicous: 说不定工作遇到画家
Nicous: Maybe he met an artist at work.
Tasha:你看
Tasha: Look.
Jack: 就是觉得你一点反馈没有
Jack: It seemed like you weren't giving any feedback.
Katrina: 嗯我感觉可能也是我
Katrina: Hmm, I felt it might be me.
Katrina: 他可能在他的那个呃视角
Katrina: Maybe from his perspective,
Katrina: 他已经就表达的够明显
Katrina: He thought he was being obvious enough.
Katrina: 但是我一直都没有
Katrina: But I never really...
Katrina: 我我我后来觉得可能是这个原因
Katrina: Later I thought it might be because of that.
Katrina: 因为因为北邮男是比较闷的那种性格
Katrina: Because the Beiyou guy is more of a reserved type.
Katrina: 然后我是后来就是有了落差以后
Katrina: And then after I felt the disparity,
Katrina: 我才觉得
Katrina: I realized
Katrina: 哎他之前怎么对我那么好
Katrina: How well he treated me before.
Katrina: 就是我这人有点
Katrina: I'm kinda
Katrina: 就是反射弧很长你知道吧
Katrina: Slow to react, you know?
Nicous: 他就觉得嗯
Nicous: He just feels, hmm.
Katrina: 然后跟北邮男这几个月没怎么联系以后
Katrina: And after these months without much contact with the Beiyou guy,
Jake:看看你的你
Jake: Look at your...
Jake:你你能上谷歌吗
Jake: Can you access Google?
Katrina: 没怎么联系了以后
Katrina: After not much contact,
Jake:谷歌能上吗
Jake: Can you access Google?
Katrina: 这一次脱口秀看完以后
Katrina: After watching this stand-up show,
Katrina: 他回来又找我聊天了
Katrina: He came back and started chatting with me again.
Jake:哦脱口秀你们俩去的
Jake: Oh, you both went to the stand-up show?
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 因为当时是一起看的一起喜欢的富豪
Katrina: Because at that time, we watched it together and liked that rich guy together.
Jack: OK那你怎么考虑呢
Jack: OK, so what are you planning to do?
Katrina: 我又打算这个结束以后去找他聊一聊
Katrina: I'm planning to talk to him after this ends.
Katrina: 就直接把话说清楚然后就回武汉
Katrina: Just to clear things up and then go back to Wuhan.
Katrina: 然后回武汉
Katrina: Then back to Wuhan.
Jake:Google不开
Jake: Google is not working.
Jake:Google
Jake: Google.
Jake:Google Google
Jake: Google, Google.
Katrina: 没有我做好了
Katrina: No, I got it ready.
Katrina: 90%被枪毙得准备
Katrina: 90% prepared for execution.
Jake:Google 你墙没翻吧
Jake: Google, you didn't bypass the firewall, did you?
翻了呀Tasha:
Tasha: Yes, I did.
Katrina: 没有就是表明心意吧
Katrina: No, just expressing my feelings.
Jake:你没翻 没翻
Jake: You didn't bypass it. You didn't.
Katrina: 包括他当时就搞的我有点内耗
Katrina: Including the fact that he made me feel a bit conflicted.
Katrina: 他突然一下那样子有点像断崖式暧昧
Katrina: He suddenly acted ambiguously like a cliff, you know?
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 我就觉得我要去问清楚你为啥要那样
Katrina: I just feel like I need to ask why you did that.
Jake:Google Goo
Jake: Google, Goo.
Katrina: 你当时发生什么事情
Katrina: What happened back then?
Jake:你去Google搜一个吧
Jake: Go Google it.
Jake:你去Google搜一个
Jake:随便搜个东西可以
Jake: Just search for something.
Katrina: 但是我也跟他说很多很多很多的话
Katrina: But I also said a lot, a lot to him.
Jack: 那就不知道了
Jack: Then, who knows?
Tasha:这受不了了
Tasha: I can't take this.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:怎么是个闭音啊
Jake: Why is it muted?
Katrina: 你什么
Katrina: What?
Jake:上面有Google
Jake: There's Google on it.
Jake: 你这没有网哦你闭音都放不了哎
Jake: You don't have internet, you can't even play the mute sound.
Tasha:哎这么笨啊
Tasha: Oh, so dumb.
Jake: 那你没得网
Jake: You don't have internet.
Katrina: 这我不太懂
Katrina: I don't quite get it.
Jake: 你没得网
Jake: You don't have internet.
Jake: 你怎么知道加PPT
Jake: How do you know how to add a PPT?
Katrina: 不太懂北邮男
Katrina: I don't really get Beiyou guys.
Katrina:  但是我跟北邮男当然是一个是相遇
Katrina: But with the Beiyou guy, our meeting was quite wonderful, you know?
Jake: 什么叫我知道加PPT
Jake: What do you mean I know how to add a PPT?
Katrina:  非常的奇妙你知道吧
Katrina: It was very amazing, you know?
Katrina:  就那么多学校偏偏我俩就参加了同
Katrina: Of all the schools, it just had to be us attending the same one.
Tasha:怎么办呢
Tasha: What to do?
Jake: 怎么办呢
Jake: What to do?
Katrina: 但是会带一些偶像剧的滤镜
Katrina: But it will have some idol drama filters.
Jack: 不要太在意过去的细节
Jack: Don't worry too much about the details of the past.
Jake: 怎么办呢
Jake: What to do?
Katrina:  啊我也是觉得就是现在看
Katrina: Ah, I also think that looking now...
Katrina:  所以我就打算这次就去表明一下心意
Katrina: So I plan to express my feelings this time.
Katrina:  然后就没了
Katrina: And then that's it.
Katrina:  要那要结果什么的肯定是
Katrina: As for the result, it should be...
Katrina:  男方主动吧
Katrina: The guy should take the initiative.
Katrina:  要么拒绝要么在一起
Katrina: Either reject or get together.
Katrina:  难道还要我说我们要在一起吗
Katrina: Do I have to say, "We should be together"?
Katrina:  这样吗
Katrina: Like that?
Katrina:  多那个是吧
Katrina: Isn't that too much?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Katrina:  我也不太懂
Katrina: I don't really understand.
Katrina:  我感觉我就谈一段恋爱
Katrina: I feel like I just want to have a relationship.
Katrina:  所以这个男的对我我
Katrina: So, this guy to me...
Katrina:  我也没怎么跟别人暧昧过
Katrina: I haven't really flirted with anyone else.
Katrina:  就不太懂这个
Katrina: So, I don't get this.
Jake:那他主动的
Jake: Then he should take the initiative.
Jake: 那当然他讲呢
Jake: Of course he should say it.
Jake: 他主动当然他讲
Jake: If he takes the initiative, he should say it.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm, hmm.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  所以我觉得他当时有病啊
Katrina: So, I felt he was crazy at that time.
Katrina:  所以我当然特讨厌北邮的
Katrina: So, of course, I really disliked Beiyou.
Jake:那你被北邮
Jake: Then you were surrounded by Beiyou.
Jake: 被包围了那你
Jake: Surrounded by Beiyou, so you...
Katrina:  我被北邮包围了
Katrina: I was surrounded by Beiyou.
Jake:你要不你要不
Jake: So, why don't you...
Jake: 明天你要不
Jake: Tomorrow, you...
Jake: 后天去北邮参观一下
Jake: The day after, go visit Beiyou.
Katrina:  我去过北邮
Katrina: I've been to Beiyou.
Katrina:  他带我进过两次北邮
Katrina: He took me there twice.
Jake:哦去过了是吧
Jake: Oh, you've been there, huh?
Katrina:  沙河跟海淀我都逛过了
Katrina: I've been to Shahe and Haidian.
Katrina:  我现在我现在没有看
Katrina: Now I don't really see...
Katrina:  你们几个对女朋友都挺好
Katrina: You guys are all nice to your girlfriends.
Katrina:  我觉得爱北邮的可能还行吧
Katrina: I think those who love Bei You might be okay.
Jake: 就还行吧
Jake: Yeah, probably okay.
Jake: 就是这都是精英啊
Jake: I mean, they're all elites.
Jake: 这些都是
Jake: All of them.
Nicous: 卧槽他妈他妈四个四个
Nicous: Damn, four of them, four of them!
Nicous: 逮到四个人拉我回去干啥呀
Nicous: They caught four people, why are they taking me back?
Nicous: 那我们北欧内部讨厌网安人啊
Nicous: We at Nordics really dislike cybersecurity people.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 网安哦网安哦
Jake: Cybersecurity, oh, cybersecurity.
Jake: 网安院
Jake: Cybersecurity department.
Katrina: 我我不太那个男的想法
Katrina: I, I don't really have that guy's thoughts.
Jake: 网络安全
Jake: Network security.
Katrina: 所以我现在就是调整心态
Katrina: So now I'm just adjusting my mindset.
Katrina:  就是无所谓他对我什么态度
Katrina: It doesn't matter what his attitude towards me is.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  我只是想去要一个答案而已
Katrina: I just want an answer.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  就去问一下
Katrina: Just to ask.
Katrina:  然后我就回武汉
Katrina: Then I'll go back to Wuhan.
Jake: 你现在有网了
Jake: You have internet now.
Katrina: 如果我们俩在一起我就多待一天
Katrina: If we are together, I'll stay one more day.
Jake: 你有网了
Jake: You have internet now.
Katrina:  但是我已经做好了
Katrina: But I've already prepared.
Jake:你就搞呗
Jake: Just do it.
Katrina:  90%被拒绝可能因为你
Katrina: 90% chance of rejection, because of you.
Katrina:  你很明显
Katrina: It's obvious.
Katrina:  你翻以前的聊天记录跟现在就不一样
Katrina: Your old chat records and now are different.
Katrina:  你懂吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 就是会有落差
Katrina: There's going to be a gap.
Katrina:  但是偶尔一次还行啊
Katrina: But once in a while is fine.
Katrina:  没有那那那就是很明显的
Katrina: Otherwise it's very obvious.
Katrina:  之前秒回到现在就是一个小时回
Katrina: Instant replies before, now it takes an hour.
Katrina:  一下午不回那种
Katrina: Not replying all afternoon.
Nicous: 我个人
Nicous: Personally...
Jake: 在哪里啊
Jake: Where is it?
Jake: 哎Google
Jake: Hey, Google.
Tasha:Google Google也有怎么办
Tasha: Google, what if Google has it too?
Katrina:  哎我当时也这么想的
Katrina: I thought the same at the time.
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Nicous: 就是一个消息一下午才回
Nicous: He takes an entire afternoon to reply to a message.
Jake: Google
Nicous: 那不肯定在跟别人聊天
Nicous: He must be chatting with someone else.
Jake: Google
Tasha:什么什么时候才回
Tasha: When does he reply?
Nicous: 就是他发个消息
Nicous: He sends a message,
Nicous: 他奶奶一下午才回
Nicous: and his grandma replies in the afternoon.
Nicous: 一下午才回他在
Nicous: He replies in the afternoon.
Jake: 他在干嘛
Jake: What's he doing?
Jake: 上班
Jake: Working?
Katrina:  不知道啊
Katrina: No idea.
Nicous: 哦他没上班
Nicous: Oh, he's not working.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  没有没有
Katrina: No, no.
Katrina:  他有自己的一个项目组在干嘛
Katrina: He's got his own project team.
Nicous: 他有项目组
Nicous: He has a project team?
Nicous: 那也不能一个下午才回
Nicous: He still shouldn't take an entire afternoon to reply.
Katrina:  对啊而且那次断崖是很奇怪
Katrina: Yeah, and that sudden break was really strange.
Katrina:  就是之前两个月一直在每天聊天
Katrina: For two months, we were chatting every day.
Katrina:  然后12月的时候我从北京回去以后
Katrina: Then in December, after I got back from Beijing,
Jake:唉 没有啊
Jake: Oh, nothing.
Katrina:  就我俩见了一面
Katrina: We met once,
Katrina:  回去就不说话
Katrina: and after that, we stopped talking.
Katrina:  因为他也不主动说话
Katrina: Because he didn't start the conversation.
Katrina:  我感觉我老主动贴人家也没什么意思
Katrina: I felt like it was pointless to always be the one reaching out.
Katrina:  然后我也不说话
Katrina: So I stopped talking too.
Katrina:  然后就后来一两个月都不说话
Katrina: And then we didn't talk for one or two months.
Jake: 另有新欢
Jake: He's got someone new.
Katrina:  是吧我觉得你再怎么忙
Katrina: Right? No matter how busy you are.
Katrina:  然后我后来就问他
Katrina: So I asked him later.
Katrina:  我他妈甚至我我
Katrina: I even, I...
Katrina:  我是一个非常直接的小女孩
Katrina: I'm a very straightforward girl.
Katrina:  我直接问他
Katrina: I asked him directly.
Katrina:  我说我在北京跟你吃饭相处这两天
Katrina: I said, during our time together in Beijing,
Katrina:  我做了什么很让你很下头的事情吗
Katrina: did I do something that turned you off?
就是因为在我的视角只有那个人
Katrina: Because from my perspective, it was just him,
Katrina:  就是因为在我的视角
Katrina: because from my perspective,
Katrina:  只有那个人
Katrina: it was just him,
Katrina:  突然就是我突然对他很下头
Katrina: and suddenly, I was completely turned off.
Katrina:  我才会就完全断了那种
Katrina: That's why I completely cut things off.
Nicous: 他怎么说的
Nicous: What did he say?
Katrina:  他说他这两天在忙那个项目
Katrina: He said he's been busy with that project these past two days.
Katrina:  通宵了两晚上
Katrina: Stayed up all night for two nights.
Katrina:  就是没有一点精神
Katrina: He's just exhausted.
Nicous: 晚上喝的也是一样的
Nicous: He drank the same stuff at night too.
Katrina:  鬼知道啊
Katrina: Who knows?
Nicous: 但是我啥时候问的
Nicous: But when did I ask?
Katrina:  但是我的想 12月12月十几号在北京
Katrina: But my thought is around December, like mid-December in Beijing.
Jake:12月
Jake: December.
Katrina:  回去了以后一个星期他没让我说话
Katrina: After he went back, he didn't let me talk for a week.
Katrina:  我就问他了
Katrina: So I asked him.
Katrina:  我说啥意思
Katrina: I asked what he meant.
Katrina:  然后他说他那个
Katrina: Then he said that...
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Katrina:  嗯什么忙项目通宵了两天
Katrina: Um, something about being busy with the project, staying up all night for two days.
Katrina:  是吧
Katrina: Right?
Katrina:  所以所以就少了少了
Katrina: So, so it became less and less.
Tasha:我只定了这一个
Tasha: I only booked this one.
Tasha:节点倒是有很多有消息
Tasha: There are many updates on the nodes.
Jake: 有消息一天
Jake: There are updates every day.
一天Jake:
Jake: Every day.
Tasha:充了一个月
Tasha: I recharged for a month.
Tasha:一个月一个月充
Tasha: A month, month recharge.
Jake:换一换个新加坡的
Jake: Switch to one from Singapore.
Jake: 换一换件
Jake: Switch it.
Jake: 新加坡的
Jake: From Singapore.
Jake: 新加坡
Jake: Singapore.
Jake: 我懂
Jake: I get it.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 嗯这样就行了
Jake: Hmm, that works.
Tasha:节点就不一样吗
Tasha: The nodes are different, right?
Katrina:  为什么这个叫XBZ
Katrina: Why is this called XBZ?
Katrina:  为什么是什么时候出书啊
Katrina: When is it going to be published?
Jake: 确实差不多
Jake: Pretty much the same.
Tasha:哈哈换了有什么用
Tasha: Haha, what's the use of switching?
Katrina:  唉 我好像听过他歌是吧
Katrina: Sigh, I think I've heard his song, right?
Jake: 他  新加坡好
Jake: He, Singapore is good.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:对哦
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 新加坡牛逼啊
Jake: Singapore is awesome!
Jake: 然后给你充给你充给你充
Jake: Then I'll top it up for you, top it up for you, top it up for you.
Katrina:  这个
Katrina: This one.
Jake: 给他upgrade就帮助老板赚钱啊
Jake: Upgrading it helps the boss make money.
Jake: 啊这是以后给我们发工资
Jake: Ah, this will be our future salaries.
Katrina:  老师不是
Katrina: Not the teacher.
Katrina:  提高他的效率
Katrina: Improve his efficiency.
Katrina:  让他写论文更快
Katrina: Make him write papers faster.
Jake:对对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Katrina:  加油
Katrina: Keep it up.
Katrina:  到时候你直接成我们这个工作室
Katrina: By then, you'll directly join our studio.
Tasha:20美金一个月
Tasha: 20 dollars a month.
2Tasha:0刀一个月啊
Tasha: 20 bucks a month, huh?
Jake: 20刀1个月
Jake: 20 bucks a month.
Tasha:你不是跟我说
Tasha: Didn't you tell me...
Jake:我这多少钱
Jake: How much is it?
Katrina:  CHAT GPT 4吗
Katrina: Is it CHAT GPT 4?
Katrina:  还是3.5
Katrina: Or 3.5?
Tasha:20刀一个月
Tasha: 20 bucks a month.
Jake:但是
Jake: But...
Katrina: 那你可以用3.5也够了
Katrina: Then you can use 3.5, it's enough.
Katrina:  感觉 3.5淘宝买一个20块钱
Katrina: Feels like 3.5, you can buy it on Taobao for 20 yuan.
Tasha:那不就一一万
Tasha: Isn't that like 10,000...
Tasha:1万6人民币一个月
Tasha: 16,000 RMB a month.
Jake: 呃确实
Jake: Uh, indeed.
Tasha:你之前怎么跟我说的
Tasha: How did you tell me before?
Jake: 我忘了
Jake: I forgot.
Katrina: 直接用他的号吧
Katrina: Just use his account.
Tasha:他跟我说他二三十人民币一个月
Tasha: He told me it's 20-30 RMB a month.
Jake: 我没说 新加坡新币
Jake: I didn't say. Singapore dollars.
Jake: 新币新币差不多
Jake: Singapore dollars, about the same.
Jake: 但是好好的
Jake: But it's all good.
Lucia:上次上次那个微微好像说过
Lucia: Last time, last time, Weiwei seemed to have said it.
女嘉宾:为什么你们GPT4那么便宜
Female Guest: Why is your GPT-4 so cheap?
Lucia:对为什么
Lucia: Yeah, why?
Katrina:  你们明天还来吗
Katrina: Are you coming tomorrow?
Tasha:他说他用他信用卡充的
Tasha: He said he topped it up with his credit card.
Tasha:然后我现在问他多少钱
Tasha: Now I ask him how much it costs.
Katrina: 啊别搞得像最后一面啊
Katrina: Ah, don't make it look like the last time we'll meet.
Tasha:他说价格不一样啊
Tasha: He said the price is different.
Lucia:你确定不是你之前记错了吗
Lucia: Are you sure you didn't remember it wrong before?
Jake: 可能是记错
Jake: Maybe I did.
Tasha:他之前是多少钱来着
Tasha: How much was it before?
Tasha:三四十人民币
Tasha: Thirty or forty RMB.
Katrina:  明天不来吗
Katrina: Not coming tomorrow?
Lucia:对对对啊
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Nicous: 这么便宜
Nicous: That cheap?
Lucia:是这么说的
Lucia: That's what they said.
Lucia:但是我感觉他肯定错订单了
Lucia: But I feel like they definitely got the order wrong.
Katrina:  明天星期几啊
Katrina: What day is it tomorrow?
Nicous: 这么便宜
Nicous: That cheap?
Katrina:  我已经过了
Katrina: I already passed.
Jake:可能是20刀吗
Jake: Could it be 20 dollars?
Katrina:  就是没有星期日
Katrina: There's no Sunday.
Jake:不可能吧
Jake: No way.
Katrina:  工作日和工作日
Katrina: Weekdays and weekdays.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Tasha:明天早上什么时候走
Tasha: When are we leaving tomorrow morning?
Katrina:  问他后天是不是23号中午退房
Katrina: Ask him if we're checking out at noon on the 23rd.
Jake: 你说23号中午退房
Jake: You mean check out at noon on the 23rd?
Jake: 明天把这收拾收拾
Jake: Let's tidy up tomorrow.
Jake: 然后划划水
Jake: Then we can relax a bit.
Jake: 明天没有什么任务
Jake: We don't have any tasks tomorrow.
Jake: 划划水
Jake: Just relax.
Katrina:  明天那我睡到12点喽
Katrina: So I can sleep until noon?
Jake: 可以没问题
Jake: Sure, no problem.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia:太好了耶
Lucia: Great!
Lucia:明天可以不用戴眼镜了
Lucia: I don't have to wear glasses tomorrow.
Jake: 明天戴眼镜戴眼镜
Jake: No, you have to wear glasses tomorrow.
Jake: 戴眼镜划水
Jake: Wear glasses and relax.
Jake: 加油划水
Jake: Just take it easy.
Katrina:  OK那我把明天把那风铃做了
Katrina: OK, then I'll make that wind chime tomorrow.
Jake: 对但是明天早上
Jake: Yes, but tomorrow morning.
Jake: 明天早上吃午饭的时候
Jake: When you have lunch tomorrow morning.
Jake: 你们在外面吃午饭
Jake: Have lunch outside.
Jake: 然后我把屋子再扫一遍
Jake: Then I'll sweep the house again.
Jake: 你们都在啊
Jake: You'll all be here.
Jake: 你们把这个房就是房间给
Jake: You'll take care of this room.
Jake: 就是还是现在的
Jake: Just like it is now.
Jake: 这么好看的样子哦
Jake: This looks so nice.
Jake: 白天扫晚上
Jake: Sweep during the day, and at night...
Katrina: 那我明天叠个被子
Katrina: Then I'll fold the blanket tomorrow.
Jake: 然后就可以拆了
Jake: Then you can take it apart.
Jake: 呵呵呵对
Jake: Haha, yes.
Jake: 给你充钱
Jake: I'll top up your account.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha:老板我两个杜卡七怎么办
Tasha: Boss, what about my two card readers?
Jake: 你两个读卡器我给你送回去呗
Jake: I'll return your two card readers.
Violet: 我拿一个吧
Violet: I'll take one.
Violet: 这两个是你的
Violet: These two are yours.
Katrina:  我已经过了
Katrina: I've already done it.
Katrina: 我说偷窥小情侣
Katrina: I said I spied on the couple.
过来就好了
Just come over.
他现在在翻旧账啊
He's digging up old issues now.
Katrina: 啊 最讨厌翻旧账的男的
Katrina: Ah, I hate guys who dig up old issues.
他他他现在跟我说他之前就是
He's telling me now that he...
大概从从大二下半年开始
From the second half of his sophomore year
到大四上半年
To the first half of his senior year
所有桃花都是被我耽误的
All his romantic opportunities were ruined by me.
Katrina:  啊他跟我说他去
Katrina: Ah, he told me he went
Katrina:  他去不同的那
Katrina: He went to different places
Katrina:  每次带都不同的妹子
Katrina: Every time with different girls
Shure的女友:你什么东西我不能看
Shure: What is it that I can't see?
Nicous: 谁谁要你这么喜欢他
Nicous: Who told you to like him so much?
Jake: 哎XBZ
Jake: Hey XBZ
Jake:在这了我靠
Jake: It's here, damn.
Jake: 二楼搞得不太好
Jake: The second floor isn't done well.
Katrina: 一些难以言喻的事情
Katrina: Some unspeakable things.
Katrina:  你俩真特摇滚了
Katrina: You two are really rock and roll.
Katrina:  嗯很rell的一对情侣
Katrina: A very real couple.
Jake: XBZ XBZ
Katrina: XBZ
Jake: 快快快快快快
Jake: Quick, quick, quick, quick, quick.
Violet: 不是说我
Violet: Not talking about me.
Violet: 是说哪一个
Violet: Which one are you talking about?
Violet: 这个传输的速度快一点
Violet: This one transfers faster.
Violet: 没有没有没有
Violet: No, no, no.
Violet: 就是这个
Violet: It's this one.
Violet: 哪个读法是传输速度快一点
Violet: Which one reads and transfers faster.
Nicous: 就这个
Nicous: This one.
Jake: 这个好还是那个好
Jake: Is this one better or that one?
Violet: 绿色的方块
Violet: The green block.
Jake: 绿的
Jake: The green one?
Lucia:都行我可以
Lucia: Both are fine, I can work with either.
Nicous: 窄的最好
Nicous: The narrow one is the best.
Violet: 嗯就是扁扁的
Violet: Yeah, the flat one.
Nicous: 对对对
Nicous: Yes, yes, exactly.
Jake: 那这个带走好好好
Jake: Alright, let's take this one then.
Violet: ok
Violet: Okay.
Jake: 行
Jake: Sure.
Lucia:你看你只要方便就就行
Lucia: You see, as long as it's convenient for you.
Lucia:就是只要只要也方便
Lucia: Just as long as it's convenient.
Lucia:发到发到群里就行
Lucia: Just post it in the group.
Lucia:对我们其实有一个炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Yeah, we actually have scrambled eggs.
Nicous: 但是有人在用
Nicous: But someone is using it.
Jake: 第一天
Jake: On the first day.
Nicous: 真的有人在打吗
Nicous: Is someone really using it?
Jake:第一天用一下
Jake: Using it for the first day.
Jake: 对第一天然后最后一天用一下
Jake: Yeah, on the first day and the last day.
Jake: 嗯原来是希望每一场都用一下
Jake: I originally hoped to use it every time.
Jake: 结果吧就自然而然的就哈哈哈
Jake: But then it just naturally... hahaha.
Lucia:导演你这个你知道
Lucia: Director, you know...
Lucia:后期剪辑工作量就特别大
Lucia: The post-production editing workload is huge.
Jake: 呵呃
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 这什么
Katrina: What's this?
Jake: 没有这个这些都是一直在录的
Jake: No, these have been recording continuously.
Katrina: 找你的耳机呀
Katrina: Looking for your earphones?
Jake: 所以
Jake: So...
Katrina:  哈哈找笔记本
Katrina: Haha, looking for the notebook.
Lucia:是为了方便你
Lucia: It's to make it easier for you.
Lucia:之后但是他以为你
Lucia: But he thought you...
Lucia:因为你其实其实做数字的
Lucia: Because you actually work with numbers.
Lucia:就如果说要剪
Lucia: So if you want to cut it...
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia:为了方便你就知道是哪一块
Lucia: To make it easier for you to know which part it is.
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, exactly.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yep.
Tasha:你不带的话你明天还会走
Tasha: If you don't take it, you will leave tomorrow.
Nicous: 后备箱请你今天怎么放
Nicous: How are you going to put it in the trunk today?
Jake: 我们每天对3次
Jake: We check three times a day.
Nicous: 放后备箱
Nicous: Put it in the trunk.
Lucia:你是一个氛围氛围感道具
Lucia: You are a prop for the atmosphere.
Nicous: 还是后备箱
Nicous: Still in the trunk.
Violet: 放后坐
Violet: Put it in the back seat.
Lucia:因为我不是导演
Lucia: Because I'm not the director.
Nicous: 上不了放不了
Nicous: It won't fit, can't put it.
Violet: 然后 对
Violet: And yes.
Katrina:  那你带后备箱哈哈哈
Katrina: Then you carry the trunk, haha.
Nicous: 明天再来
Nicous: Come again tomorrow.
Violet: 你明天或者后天再来
Violet: Come tomorrow or the day after.
Jake: 啊明天再来
Jake: Ah, come again tomorrow.
Jake: 后天也可以再来
Jake: The day after is fine too.
Nicous: 我希望明天
Nicous: I hope it's tomorrow.
Nicous: 过两天再拿钱
Nicous: Get the money in a couple of days.
Nicous: 我靠
Nicous: Damn.
Nicous: 我怎么拿钱啊
Nicous: How do I get the money?
Nicous: 柳山
Nicous: Liushan.
Jake: 过两天
Jake: In a couple of days.
Violet: 我这有车
Violet: I have a car here.
Jake: 都在上面
Jake: It's all on top.
Violet: 或者打车回去
Violet: Or take a cab back.
Violet: 那现在搞呗
Violet: Then let's do it now.
Nicous: 笔记本不行啊
Nicous: The notebook doesn't work.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 你哪个笔记本呢
Jake: Which notebook?
Jake: 就一个笔记本
Jake: Just one notebook.
Jake: 你在我床上啊
Jake: You're on my bed?
我们我们班那个学生节的时候
Student: Our class during the student festival...
Jake: 你看看
Jake: Look.
Violet: 好像不是很平常
Violet: Doesn't seem very usual.
Violet: 就是拍我们班
Violet: Just filming our class.
Jake: 啊这里
Jake: Here.
Violet: 班学生节一般都是就是舞台节目
Violet: The student festival is usually just stage programs.
Jake: 这叫ego life吧
Jake: This is called ego life, right?
Jake: 这个大家都有自己的生活
Jake: Everyone has their own life.
Lucia:家都有自己的生活
Lucia: Everyone has their own life.
Lucia:这个翻译
Lucia: This translation.
Nicous: 这么这么解释也好
Nicous: This explanation works too.
Katrina:  slogan都有了我去
Katrina: The slogan is ready, wow.
Jake:好嘞明天见
Jake: Alright, see you tomorrow.
Jake: 已经看到自己的这宣传片了
Jake: I've already seen my promo video.
Nicous: 你什么时候能关山啊
Nicous: When can you close the deal?
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye bye.
Katrina:  滚没带
Katrina: No, I didn't bring it.
Katrina:  带你去好不好
Katrina: I'll take you, okay?
Katrina:  你在后面
Katrina: You stay behind.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 我24
Katrina: I'm 24.
Katrina:  我23号约了他吃晚饭
Katrina: I have a dinner date with him on the 23rd.
Jake: 雨萱你看过这一段吗
Jake: Yuxuan, have you seen this part?
Nicous: 我操
Nicous: Damn.
Nicous: 如果成了
Nicous: If it works out...
Jake: 来说说
Jake: Go ahead and talk about it.
Katrina:  什么东西啊
Katrina: What's that?
Nicous: 如果成了24号我们一起去动物园
Nicous: If it works out, let's go to the zoo on the 24th.
Katrina:  你咋知道
Katrina: How do you know?
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Huh?
Katrina:  你咋知道
Katrina: How do you know?
Jake:哦
Katrina:  我本来打算23号表白成功
Katrina: I planned to confess on the 23rd.
Jake: 确实本来就是
Jake: That's how it was supposed to be.
Katrina:  24号就跟他去的
Katrina: And then go with him on the 24th.
Jake:事实上就是这样的
Jake: That's exactly how it is.
Lucia:主要主要
Lucia: Mainly, mainly...
Lucia:他们确实也没解释清楚具体想拍什么
Lucia: They didn't really explain what they wanted to shoot.
Katrina:  动物园
Katrina: Zoo.
Katrina: 应该是就动物园野生有点远
Katrina: Probably the zoo, it's a bit far.
Lucia:但我后来发现
Lucia: But I later found out...
Lucia:可能是因为导演自己确实不知道
Lucia: Maybe the director himself wasn't sure.
Nicous: 我朋友准备20双租车险给我
Nicous: My friend is preparing 20 cars for rent.
Nicous: 要不要喊人
Nicous: Should we call people?
Nicous: 如果扯了我们一起去哈哈哈
Nicous: If it works out, let's all go together, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的假的
Katrina: Haha, really?
Katrina: 我在小红书上刷到了
Katrina: I saw it on Little Red Book.
Katrina:  我就住动物园附近
Katrina: I live near the zoo.